il a le goût des vacances ou des
dimanches matin le croissant et la
viennoiserie française par excellence
mais le confectionner à la perfection et
tout un art chaque année depuis 18 ans
le concours du meilleur croissant au
beurre désigny AOP récompense les
apprenants boulangers de moins de 20 ans
le 28 mars dernier c'est Lina Méziane
qui a remporté la sélection régionale
elle est élève en deuxième année bac pro
boulangerie pâtisserie au lycée hôtelier
de Guyancourt elle représentera
l'Île-de-France lors de la finale le 9
et 10 mai prochain en Normandie c'était
mon premier concours donc moi je partais
pour voilà pour gagner mais je voulais
aussi surtout engranger de l'expérience
et bah
j'ai vu quand j'ai vu que j'ai remporté
la finale régionale j'étais super
contente
je voulais absolument faire ce concours
depuis l'année dernière quand le prof
m'en avait parlé donc j'étais impatiente
et pour moi c'est mon premier concours
donc forcément
c'est une expérience que je voulais
avoir
tournage détaillage façonnage cuisson
faire un bon croissant de s'improvise
pas Lina on a bien conscience elle
s'entraîne sans relâche depuis plus d'un
mois il faut être patient minutieux
pointilleux faut voilà faut faire
attention à tous les petits détails et
il faut être très rigoureux aussi donc
là ce que j'ai fait pour avoir justement
cette régularité c'est que je vais
mesurer je vais mesurer mon abaisse pour
que elle fasse un certain nombre de
centimètres et qu'ensuite tous mes
croissances soient au même nombre
pendant qu'on a cours on a deux TP par
semaine et pendant cette épée là de 5
heures ben moi j'étais dans une pièce à
part où je m'entraînais que sur ça que
sur les croissants et ensuite bah là
comme vous voyez pendant les vacances
aussi je veux bien pour la finale Ina
devra réaliser 12 croissants et une
viennoiserie créative de son choix pour
cela elle peut compter sur les conseils
avisés de son professeur il
l'accompagnera le jour J en Normandie
Lina c'est une compétitrice donc j'avais
pas tout ce côté à gérer elle s'est elle
sait où elle veut aller elle sait où
elle va
après vykeva il le résultat sera on
verra bien quoi j'ai toujours aimé
cuisiner avec ma maman j'ai toujours vu
cuisiner j'ai su depuis toute petite que
je voulais être pâtissière et oui ça en
fait ça a toujours été une évidence pour
moi goût esthétique dextérité
originalité ou encore régularité rien ne
sera laissé au hasard le gagnant de la
sélection nationale remportera un stage
animé par un meilleur ouvrier de France
réponse dans quelques jours